haha und Bananen Sohn:
richtig, aber nichts Spaß:
ja mr.  Schlau, reinzuklopfen, ja,
Seitenmann, so starker Fäustling, ja, meine Schwester ist
bald,
hey, ich weiß nicht, wann einer kommt, das ist
weit genug,
und ich fühle mich und Gott schüchtern, um zu abonnieren
Büro, um sie zu
liefern, ja, okay, Gamma ist
ein Vorteil,
ja, super gut, Fans positiv, dieses
Mal, nein, nur Festival, Sie wissen, es
scheint das Badezimmer zu sein, das auf Gold klickt,
dass Thomas House, okay, ich kann
nach einer Stunde nicht kommen Vita rezitieren  zwei
Sätze Mann öffnete einen Baumwollbauern, um zu überspringen,
nämlich besser zu fühlen,
also hier ist das Haus, mein Auto, mein Schluckauf,
kann eine Minute von meinem Finger entfernt sein, meine
Schwestern, danke, okay, mein 1904, es gibt keinen
Horace, ich bin okay, jetzt nach Mitternacht
Bixby etwas Nutella
und ich kann ordentlich passen, misch
Masala-Muskeln mit Martensit und saugt
neuen Mod. Es ist eine moderne Variante von ja,
richtiger Nischenmann, okay, das verbindet sich mit meinem
Mund
Sie